Transcriber: Özge Belen
Gözden geçirme: Emel Çırakoğlu
Herkese merhaba!
Bugün sizi gastronomide
bir yolculuğa çıkaracağım.
İştahınızı ve merakınızı uyandıracağım
ama yemek tarifi vermeyeceğim.
Ben Gastronomi ve Mutfak
sanatları mezunuyum.
Hem de bir okulda olduğumuz için
şu an, TED Bodrum Koleji’nde,
konuşmamı birazcık okul, eğitim
temasında hazırlamak istedim.
Kozmos çünkü çok geniş bir konu.
Gastronomi de öyle.
Şimdi yemeğimiz, tabağımız,
mutfakta yapılan o ürünler,
sofraya gelene kadarki süreç...
Biraz buna değineceğim.
Çünkü çok fazla konuyu, çok fazla
interdisipliner bilimi içeriyor.
Öncelikle gastronomi, gastro mide demek,
nomi ise yasa anlamına geliyor.
Yani yediğimiz yemeklerin,
midemize giren her ürünün arka planını,
bilimini içeren bir konu.
Dolayısıyla pek çok bilim dalını da
interdisipliner konuları da
içerisinde barındırıyor.
Buna öncelikle ben,
ziraatten, tarımdan başlamak istiyorum.
Çünkü yediğimiz bütün ürünler toprakta
yetişiyor ya da ağaçta yetişiyor.
Bunu bilmeyen bir aşçı, bunu bilmeyen
bir şef aslında çok doğru bir tabak
ortaya koyamıyor diye düşünüyorum.
Bir ürün, bir topraktan yetişen bir fide
ziraat ve tarım konusunda kendini
büyüterek mutfağa geliyorsa, biz de o
yemeğin arkasındaki bütün o evrensel
kuramı hissetmemiz gerekiyor.
Nedir bu kural?
Bu da diğer bilimlerden gelen bir konu.
Psikoloji, sosyoloji, antropoloji.
Yediğimiz yemekler, içinde bulunduğumuz
ruh hali, açlık, tokluk duygumuz, ailemiz,
kültürümüz, kökenimiz, tarihsel yolculuk,
tamamen bunlarla alakalı.
Önümüze gelen tabağın arkasındaki hikaye
çok derin, çok çok evrensel
başka konuları temsil ediyor.
Ziraatten, tarımdan bahsettim.
Ürün yetişti, mutfağa geldi.
Satın alma yapıldı.
Genellikle kimse çok fazla gastronomi ile
matematik konusunu, mühendislik konusunu
bir arada kullanmaz.
Ama ben birazcık bugün bundan da
bahsetmek istiyorum.
Çünkü matematik hayatımızın her yerinde.
Sadece bir yemek tarifini,
üç kişilik tarifi üç yüz kişiye çıkarırken
matematik hesabı yapmaktansa
ya da bir ekmek tarifini formüle bağlayıp
ekmek haline dönüştürmekten
yanı sıra mutfakta biz
satın alma ve maliyet yapıyoruz.
Dolayısıyla matematik bilmeyen bir aşçı,
matematik bilmeyen bir gastronomi uzmanı
bu yolculuğunda çok da başarılı olamıyor.
Matematiği de bir araya, matematiği de
birazcık böyle giriş yaptıysak şimdi
birazcık da mühendislik ve mimarlık
konusundan bahsetmek istiyorum.
Burada çok tatlı öğrenciler var.
Kulis arkasında da demin
biraz sohbet ettik.
Çoğu arkadaşımız,
ben mimar olmak istiyorum ama aslında
gastronomi de düşünmüştüm dedi bana.
Aslında bu iki konu birbirinden
çok da uzak değil.
Bir mimar herhangi bir gastronomi ile
ilgili bir konunun, yani bir restoranın,
bir kafenin mutfağını tasarlayabilir, bir
yemek okulunun mutfağını inşa edebilir,
mimarlık olarak çizebilir.
Aynı şekilde bir mühendis tabak yaparken,
biz mimarlık ve mühendislik
bilgilerinden yararlanıyoruz.
Eğer farkındaysanız çok başarılı
restoranların, çok başarılı şeflerin
tabaklarına baktığınız zaman,
demin bahsettiğim o ziraatten,
tarımdan gelen, o fideden gelen
duyguyu, psikolojiyi, sosyolojiyi,
antropoloji, matematiği ve mühendisliği,
tabağa yansıttığını görürsünüz.
Birazcık da yemek yapmaktan,
yani, mutfağın içindeki
o sürece değinmek istiyorum.
Burada da yemeğin kimyası.
Ne demek yemeğin kimyası?
Okulda, ben gastronomide okurken
hocamızın söylediği bir söz vardı.
Böyle kocaman tahtaya yazardı.
“Cooking is a chemical reaction.
You’re a chemist and
kitchen is a laboratory.” derdi bize.
Yani, yemek pişirme
kimyasal bir tepkimedir.
Sizler birer kimyagersiniz ve
mutfak bir laboratuvar derdi.
Biz o zaman çok anlamazdık.
Biz aşçı olacağız, şef olacağız diye
okula giden öğrencilerdik.
Ama ben, şu anda, meslek hayatımda
bunu her gün çok çok iyi anlıyorum.
Çünkü yemek pişirmek gerçekten
kimyasal bir tepkime.
Siz kekin kabardığını
ya da bir balığın asitle piştiğini
mutfakta gerçekten gözünüzle görerek
bu kimyayı hissedebiliyorsunuz.
Şimdi kimyayı da aldık cebimize.
Birazcık mühendislik, mimarlıktan
bahsetmiştim, onları aldık cebimize.
Peki, birazcık politikadan
bahsetmek istiyorum.
Siyaset bilimi de
çünkü gastronominin bir konusu.
Eğer farkındaysanız yabancı ülkelerde,
özellikle İtalya örneğini vermek isterim.
Dünyada çok tanınan,
çok bilinen bir mutfak.
Bizim ülkemizin değerleri,
bizim ülkemizin ürünleri.
İtalya'dan geri mi?
Hayır.
Belki çok çok daha hatta iyi.
Ama politikada gıdanın
kendine edindiği yer,
politikada gıdanın korunduğu yer,
çok değerli, çok önemli.
Biz gıda politikalarımızı
düzgün planlayabilirsek,
şu an içinde bulunduğumuz bu süreci de,
yani et fiyatlarının gitmesi, çiftçinin
ürünü üretememesi, hayal kırıklıkları,
mutsuzluk, umutsuzluk konuları ve
sorunları da çözülüyor doğal olarak.
Gıda politikalarını da birazcık
cebimize koyduk.
Başka ne var?
Başka hangi bilimler var?
Bütün bilimler, bütün bilim,
interdisipliner alanlar
gastronomiden etkileniyor.
Bunların en başında gelenleri de
beslenme tabii ki.
Çünkü yediğimiz yiyeceklerin içindeki
beslenme öğeleri asıl bizi besleyen konu.
O beslenme öğelerinin
nasıl işe yaradığı, hangi işlevlerle
vücudumuzda besin olarak geldiği
ile ilgili de bir bilim var.
Tabii ki bu da çok önemli.
Bu da biraz ziraat ile tarımla da ilgili.
Ama bu konunun da çok büyük bir etkisi
olduğunu söyleyebilirim.
Interdisipliner bir bölüm gastronomi.
Biz burada, bu okul içerisinde
matematikten bahsediyoruz,
mimarlıktan, mühendislikten bahsediyoruz.
Peki, bir de bunun sanat yönü var.
Yani, tabağımızda yemeğimizi
sunduktan sonra
bir servis görevlisi önümüze
o tabağı getiriyor.
Onun içine biz beş duyumuzu
yani görmemizi, duymamızı,
bakmamızı, dokunmamızı,
hissetmemizi ve işitmemizi içerisine
koyarak o tabağa bakarsak
yediğimiz yemekten çok daha büyük
bir iştah duyuyoruz.
Çok daha büyük bir keyif alıyoruz.
Bu keyif konuları, iştah konuları
birazcık psikolojiyle ilgiliydi,
ondan da bahsettim.
Ama sanat konusu, yani, tabağın tasarım
süreci, kullanılan renkler, inşası,
yüksek bir tabak yapmak, siyah tabağın
üstüne beyaz soslar koymak, koyu renkli
bir tabağı daha nötr tonlarda ve
sebzelerle süslemek bizim iştahımızı
doğal olarak arttıran diğer
unsurlardan biri.
Şimdi evren, gastronomi evreni
çok geniş, çok büyük.
Belki aşçı değilsiniz, belki şef olma
hayaliniz yok ama bir mimarsanız
emin olun iyi bir aşçısınız.
Matematikle uğraşıyorsanız emin olun iyi
tarif, iyi formül yapabilen birisiniz.
Sanatla uğraşıyorsanız emin olun
yaptığınız evinizde herhangi bir yemek
çok güzel bir tabağa dönüşebilir.
İyi bir psikolog, iyi bir sosyologsanız
evinizde, ailenizde onları
besleyen güzel tabaklar,
güzel öğünler sunabilirsiniz.
Bunların haricinde herkes
bence gerçekten bir aşçı.
Herkes, bence, gerçekten
beslenmekle ilgili bir...
Her anne baba iyi bir aşçı,
diye düşünüyorum.
Bunun altını çizerek gastronominin,
evrenin, bu dünyanın çok geniş olduğunu,
herkesi de bu dünyaya davet
etmek istiyorum.
Beni dinlediğiniz için
çok teşekkür ederim.